as you may know my dear friend the
apostate Prophet has been defending
Israel against Relentless abuse from
keyboard jihadis and their allies who
want to see the nation literally wiped
off the map and he was recently told by
some people with the relevant
connections that if he comes to Israel
he can visit the sites of the October
7th attacks meet with some survivors and
view video footage that hasn't been
released to the public AP decided to go
but didn't want to go alone so he asked
me if I would take a trip to Israel with
him that sounded like a great idea to me
especially if we get anywhere near the
Jordan River at which point I will
probably forcibly baptize him Nacho
Libre style and I just thought it would
be a good idea if
you full immersion of course so we've
been putting together a schedule and
expanding our plans and the duration of
the trip because we have a lot of video
ideas for a bunch of different locations
I'll probably end up making videos with
clickbaity titles like I took an atheist
to the empty tomb of Jesus then this
happened and AP will probably make
videos with titles like I'm an atheist
so no one can make me think seriously
about anything not quite as catchy as my
titles but what do you expect from these
poor guys we can do most of the
recording on our own we're going to rent
some equipment when we get there way
easier than bringing studio lights
across the Atlantic we're thinking about
hiring a local film crew to record the
interviews because professionals with
their equipment will get better quality
than we'll get with the equipment we're
bringing but we'll see what
happens that's as much detail as I want
to go into for now we don't want to give
a road map to any jihadis out there but
if you're in Israel and you want to hang
out while we're there send us a message
AP set up a GoFundMe to help cover the
cost if you'd like to chip in the link
is in the description box awesome videos
coming
soon